the nominations for the 94th academy
awards were just announced moments ago i
love when the nominations come out we're
joined by bandango's managing editor
that's eric davis to talk us through
some of the biggest headlines from this
year's eric we're going to start with
best actor category if we could put that
up
right away starting with javier bardem
being the ricardo's we know that
benedict cumberbatch andrew garfield for
tick tick boom will smith and king
richard and denzel washington in tragedy
of macbeth what do you make of this
category uh i love this all expected
these were all expected uh will smith
this is he becomes the third black actor
to be nominated three times
and i think he is the frontrunner of
this category love him in king richard
denzel washington also in there this is
his ninth nomination denzel has been
nominated in five consecutive decades
how about wow you know now he joins the
likes of like al pacino lawrence
uh so really great deservedly
will smith in the lead for that i have
will smith okay i think he's gonna win
all right so um what about best actress
actress in a leading role any snubs yes
in that category let's check it out yeah
you look at the list you're gonna hear
everybody talking today about
being in there lady gaga
uh probably going to be the biggest snub
of the movie there's so much buzz
but kristen stewart's not surprising
right kristen stewart is surprising
because she has been missing some
nominations on in other awards so a lot
of people didn't think she was going to
get in here you know it's divisive the
performance when you play diana and they
took some liberties with the story uh
and but it was a surprise that she's in
there that's just a contestant great
choice she did a great job very great
yeah so good but how do you explain the
snub of gaga i do think that's a you
know jared leto also did not get
nominated and so i feel like there's
something against house of gucci that
was also a bit of a divisive film you
know the italian accents what was
happening there i personally really
liked it i love lady gaga i think she
was great in it i thought she was great
i've spoken to her about it and she put
her all into it and uh i think she will
see her nominated again for for
something else soon yeah so let's talk
about actor in a supporting role do we
have that graphic this is just announced
we have
there it is kieran hines troy kotzer
jesse plemmons jk simmons and cody smith
mcphee what do you think i the big story
here is troy cotzor he becomes the
second deaf actor to ever be nominated
uh the first is marley matlin who is
also his co-star in coda it is a
beautiful film i love that film he is my
favorite nominee here uh jesse plemons
nominated for the first time kirsten
dunst also nominated they are a couple
wow
uh we have two couples also penalty cruz
and javier bardem also a couples we have
two couples nominated i guess they're
going to the ceremony oh yeah they will
be there but to see jesse was here and
everyone was raving about chris curtin
and he was saying you'll have to get a
bit yeah yeah but it's so great that
he's nominated too let's go to uh
supporting actress that category jesse
buckley and the lost daughter arianna du
bois let's talk about her judy dench in
belfast kirsten dunst in the power of
the dog as we just talked she and uh
jessie plemmons are a couple and anjanu
hey hey
just here from king richard awesome
let's talk about ariana's nomination i'm
a big fan of aria ariana dubose she
plays anita and west side story rita
moreno of course won for playing anita
in the original and why is this
significant well you know i think it's a
significant that she is a breakout she
is an afro latina in this role as well
this is very important to wear i've
spoken to her a few times during this
run and she's just lovely and brilliant
and i think she does a great job in this
film too because this film not only
reimagines the story that we know but it
also re-contextualizes it for a modern
audience that's you know having
conversations right now about race about
language about immigration about what it
means to be an american for those of us
born here and those of us who dream of
coming here from abroad and so i love
that film plus the dance numbers are
electric oh i know and off looks like at
one point even the cars were doing
ballet but ellis was here remember last
week guys she was so excited about being
in the movie i can imagine she's
probably doing the hula now wherever she
is i love that that's big for her yeah
that's that's big for her and she does a
really great job opposite will smith who
gives such a big performance which is
tough to be opposite of will smith um
i'm a big fan of animated movies so
let's talk animated feature films is uh
encanto in there encanto is in there
that's right good i love that movie that
film is big although the we don't talk
about bruno song was not submitted and
it's like up the charts right now i do
want to call flea out flea becomes the
first film to be nominated for
documentary for best international
feature and animated it is a brilliant
documentary about a refugee going from
denmark from afghanistan uh and that's a
lovely film so watch flee if you okay
okay i want to see ann canto too
everyone raves about that finally let's
talk about best picture it used to be
only five in the category now you can
nominate up to ten and so here are the
numbers big long list belfast coda don't
look up drive my car dune king richard
king richard doing very well today
licorice pizza hearing a lot about that
nightmare alley bradley cooper's in that
one power of the dog and west side story
what's your pick here well yeah i think
drive my car is the surprise that's a
japanese film and that director was also
nominated he becomes a third japanese
director to be nominated uh i like you
know i'm a big west side story fan we
just talked about it i gush about it i'm
a new yorker i love that film i think
spielberg did such a great job with that
remake i think it would probably be
between this one um as well as belfast
also awesome very well as well and you
feel good you know you want to you want
to feel good after you've done it eric
thank you so much we're so glad you came
those are your nominations that'll do it
for us we will see you tomorrow at the
table